in this country the Trump administration
is struggling to support the president's
new explanation for the missile strike
that killed Zions most of influential
military commander the president said on
Friday that general Soleimani was killed
because of threats to attack four
American embassies his defense secretary
told Face the Nation on Sunday that he's
seen no hard evidence of those threats
wheeshes jiang is at the White House for
us we should good morning what have you
learned good morning Tony well the White
House is adamant that soleimani was
about to carry out attacks on Americans
and he had to be stopped but the
Secretary of Defense caused confusion
yesterday when he contradicted one of
president Trump's most specific claims
about the nature of Seoul emani's
threats I didn't see one with regard to
for embassies defense secretary mark
Esper acknowledged Sunday that he saw no
specific threat against four US
embassies by Qasem Soleimani
contradicting president Trump who
earlier claimed that's why he authorized
a strike that killed the Iranian general
I can reveal that I believe it would
have been for embassies but Esper
insisted the lack of hard evidence did
not mean the president's assumption was
wrong what I'm saying is I assure the
president's view that probably my
expectation was they were going to go
after our embassies Esper's explanation
mirrors how other top administration
officials have tried to explain how a
threat can be both imminent and vague at
the same time those are completely
consistent thoughts but it was very
clear Qasem Soleimani himself was
plotting a broad large-scale attack
against American interests the White
House has a long wish list for changes
in Iranian behavior including curbing
nuclear weapons development and stopping
support for terror proxy groups National
Security Advisor Robert O'Brien said the
tough stance on Iran is paying off and
hinted it could force potential
negotiations Iran is being choked off
and Iran's gonna have no other choice
but to come to the table Democrats say
the discrepancies between President
Trump and his inner circle add to their
initial concerns that the hit on
Soleimani was not justified they are
overstating and exaggerating what the
intelligence shows
and when you're talking about justifying
acts that might bring us into warfare
with Iran that's a dangerous thing to do
president Trump contradicted National
Security Advisor O'Brien by tweeting he
actually couldn't care less if Iran
negotiated the House has approved a
resolution to limit mr. Trump's military
action against Iran in the Senate is
considering a similar bill gale two
Republicans have already said they would
support a measure to limit the
president's War Powers all right we
should thank you very much reporting
from Washington this morning
you